about two and a half years ago I've
watched this movie called her and it
features Samantha a superintendent
intelligence form of AI said cannot take
physical form and because she can't
appear in photographs samantha decides
to write a piece of music that will
capture a moment of her life
just like a photograph would as a
musician and an engineer and someone
raising a family of artists I thought
that this idea of musical photographs
was really powerful and I decided to
create an AI composer her name is ava
and she's an artificial intelligence
that has learned the art of music
composition by reading over 30,000
scores of history's greatest so here's
what one score looks like to the
algorithm in the matrix-like
representation
and here's what 30,000 scores written by
the likes of Mozart and Beethoven looked
like in a single frame so using deep
neural networks ava looks for patterns
in this course and from a couple of bars
of existing music it actually tries to
infer what notes should come next in
those tracks and once Ava gets queued of
those predictions it can actually build
a set of mathematical rules for that
style of music in order to create a tone
original compositions and in a way this
is kind of how we humans compose music -
it's a trial and error process during
which we may not necessarily get the
right notes all the time but we can
correct ourselves either with our
musical ear or our musical knowledge but
for Ava this process is taken from years
and years of learning decades of
learning as an artist as a musician and
a composer down to a couple of hours but
music is also a super subjective art and
we needed to teach Ava how to compose
the right music for the right person
because people have different
preferences and to do that we show to
the algorithm over 30 different category
labels for each score in our database so
those category labels are like mood or a
know density or compose a style of a
piece or the the epic during which it
was written and by seeing all this data
if I can actually
respond to very precise requirements
like the ones for example we had for a
project recently where we were
commissioned to create a piece that
would be reminiscent of a science
fiction film soundtrack and the piece
that was created is called among the
stars and it was recorded with a CMG
Orchestra in Hollywood and the great
conductor in John Neal and this is what
they recorded made by Eva
[Music]
what do you think thank you so as you've
seen AI can create beautiful pieces of
music and the best part of it is that
humans can actually bring them to life
and it's not the first time in history
that technology has a commented human
creativity live music was almost always
used in silent films to amend the
experience but the problem with live
music is that it didn't scale that means
it's really hard to cram a full symphony
into a small theater and it's really
hard to do that for every theater in the
world
so when music recording was actually
invented it allowed content creators
like film creators to have pre-recorded
and original music tailored to each and
every frame of their stories and that
was really an enhancer of creativity two
years ago two and a half years ago when
I watched this movie her eye tell to
myself that personalized music would be
the next single biggest change in how we
consume and create music because
nowadays we have interactive content
like video games that have hundreds of
hours of interactive game plays but only
two hours of music on average and means
that the music loops and loops and loop
over and over again it's not very
immersive so what we're working on is to
to make sure that AI can compose
hundreds of hours of personalized music
for those use cases where human
creativity doesn't scale and we don't
just want to do that for games
Beethoven actually wrote a piece for his
beloved called Fur Elise and imagine if
we could bring back their children to
life and if you what is sitting next to
you composing a music for your
personality and your life story or
imagine if someone like Martin Luther
King for example had a personalized area
composer then maybe then we would
remember how to dream not only as a
great speech but also as a great piece
of music part of our history and
capturing dr. King's ideals and this is
our vision at Ava to personalize music
so that each and every one of you and
every individual in the world can have
access to
personal life soundtrack based on their
story and their personality so this
moment here together at Ted is now part
of our life story so it only fell
fitting that Ava would compose music for
this moment and that's exactly what we
did so my team and I we worked on
biasing Ava on the style of the Tedd
jingle and on music that makes us feel a
sense of awe and Wonder and the result
is called the age of amazement didn't
take any eye to figure out and figure
that one out and I couldn't be more
proud to show it to you so if you can
close your eyes and enjoy the music
thank you very much
[Music]
this was for all of you thank you